From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
I'm Emily Crosby and this is December 1st, 2015 and I'm here with Mr. Vernon-Damer Jr.
at the University of Southern Mississippi at the program on oral history and cultural heritage.
And with me is John Bishop and Gouha Shankar and we're doing this interview as part of the Civil Rights History Project,
co-sponsored by the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
So thank you so much for joining us and doing the interview.
You are?
Mr. Damer, could you tell us when and where you were born and about your family history?
Yes, I was born in the Kelly's Selmet community about five miles north of Hadesburg where we are today in August 27th, 1929.
Tell me about your family.
Okay.
My dad, Vernon-F-Damer Sr.
was one of 12 children born to George, Damer, and Ellie Kelly, Damer.
He was the youngest of 12 kids, six boys and six girls.
One of the boys died in the infant so that left a family of five boys and six girls.
Being the way segregation was back in that day discrimination in the oppressive situation for blacks in Mississippi
and where the black race had very little defense from law enforcement.
My grandfather made a conscious effort to make sure that his six-female daughters had the opportunity to leave the state of Mississippi at a very young age.
It was for their own protection because it was pretty obvious at that time that the white male retreated to black male,
as if he wanted to, my grandfather, he saw this being raised born and raised in Mississippi.
And likewise, the male sons all except my father who was the youngest boy.
They left the state also and went north.
So your father is the only one?
My father was the only one to remain here.
And since he was a baby boy, I would imagine he was the closest to the parents, you know, being the baby.
And he worked on a farm.
And he made a decision to remain and not leave the state.
The old males went ahead and assimilated into the society in Chicago in those places where they were identified as Caucasians, which is fine.
Because you were going looking for a better life.
I don't fault them at all about that.
It's with situation where if you don't ask, you don't tell.
So he was not asked because of all of them, because all of them are very, very late, completed and just run off, but they look like whites.
So the simulation was not that difficult.
And they were very fortunate in landing good employment.
The females, all of them went north and they married African American men, a black man.
It's interesting that the...
Yes, it was.
Do you have a speculation about why the women did one thing and the men did something different?
No, I don't.
Probably realizing, you know, in being raised in the South, it was probably easier to find suitable black man to marry.
Not being close to affiliated with the white males in Mississippi, they feel comfortable, you know, being in the black environment.
I would just imagine that was a reason why.
And the same applied to me when I went into military in 1951, being raised in all black community.
I never really hadn't noticed how to pass when you were raised in being African American.
I was married to a dark skin African American woman and I was very comfortable.
Did the men who were assimilated, did they stay in touch with the family?
Yes, yes they did.
They would come and visit an old occasion.
One or maybe two of them would bring their wives, white with them.
And that was not hard to do at that time because due to the complexion of the family and there were other mixed races in the community.
Out of the way to work, they needed to have food increasing.
To be fair, being able to brok in the community area, they had to tire for a lot of the problems that came the light skinened Americans.
So inastaia, just being able to keep that population low, you know, because overall.
And that came out of slavery, you know, as a result of the mixing of the races by the
slave master and his family, you know.
So, so that when they come here, it's almost like the lights are passing.
Yeah.
And they they felt comfortable, you know, and moving around.
I never saw any anxiety, but being a little boy, you know, I didn't put it in any way.
You didn't eat it anyway.
Yeah, they were just people visiting.
Right.
So, my senses are I've been told by some people that Kelly Settlement and some of the other
areas, you know, as you were saying, a lot of mixed race people that there was a sense
at least among some people of being kind of in between, that they didn't really identify.
You've been saying you identify with the black community, but I've heard some people say
that they didn't identify one or another, that they sort of had independence.
There we are.
Are you aware of that?
It could have happened.
Pardon me.
But coming out of the family where I never saw any racial separation of division, my
grandparents and my parents always treated everybody the same.
My school was all black.
My church was all black.
And consequently, I didn't have any notions about going over to the other race or being
maybe out of place.
I felt very comfortable being black and like watch today.
And went through the military feeling that way.
Black and from Mississippi, oh no, you're not all you say, I am.
In other words, I'm not making an assumption to where it was.
You're not going to change who I am.
Oh, no, no, no.
And I saw that coming out of my family.
My grandfather, George Damon, which you probably want to heard of this, he was white.
You know, he was third-bring white.
His mother was white.
And his dad was German, Peter Damon, from Domstadt, Germany.
I spent my time in the military.
And he was white.
My grandfather's mother was born out of Wittlock, Laura Barnes.
And she was placed with a Milato woman to raise.
And while being there with the Milato lady who was a Barnes, because you know, they carried
a slave name on the hall.
This Milato lady was running a boarding house up in Covington County, not about 25 miles
from here.
And that's where my grandfather's mother lived and worked.
And then he was in the Domstadt family.
So he was raised in that?
Sure, the Domstadt family migrated from Germany because of economic conditions over there.
It was like five of those brothers.
And one of the older brothers settled there in the area and he became a queen with my grandfather's
mother.
And they had a child.
And then later on, my grandfather, George Damon, grew up in that environment.
And his mother, Laura, she hired this black guy, Charlie Kraft, to work for her in a business.
And I think she ran a boarding house with the woodcutters and all also, eventually.
And then she married an ex-slave, Charlie Kraft.
They went on to have nine mixed race kids.
My grandfather, George Damon, he was the oldest son.
Okay.
Yeah, he was the oldest son in that mixed race family.
Now when they got married, even though Laura, my grandfather's mother was assumed to be
Milato because she had been raised up in a Milato family.
That was okay as long as she was unmarried.
But when she married Charlie Kraft, I thought having kids.
And then the old, old white Natty, I was like, hey, we don't go.
Right, it's okay for them to be together, but not for them to be married.
Right, and to have kids.
And they started that, okay.
Kids at the end.
And then they had to leave from there and move down in the commuter guerrilla.
And why was it okay for them to be in Kelly's settlement?
Because there were a lot of Milato's, that Kelly family, which my grandmother came out of.
Okay.
My dad's mother, Helen Kelly Damer.
And by the way, her mother was also white.
She was born out of Redlock and she was put with a black family, McCone family, to be
raised.
And that's how she met it with my grandmother, Helen Kelly's, their dad warned Kelly, okay.
Because there were two, there were two on Milato and white.
So that's where you got this real light complex of the rate.
But there were other families out in our community.
Blackwise, Wilson family, Eaton family.
At one time, our family was identified, you know, it's kind of a sling.
That's where all the white Negroes live.
We talked to Mrs. Smith earlier today and she said she was called that white Negro.
Mrs. Wynn, which one?
Jeanette.
Oh, Jeanette, I know it's Jeanette.
Yeah, she said she had that same name.
Yeah, of course.
She was around Soso, Mississippi.
Yeah, that's what she was.
Yeah, she was a Musco, I know.
Helen, yeah.
Not a mixed race.
It's a, you know, the part of Mississippi, I'm from, there were few individuals but not
the families like this, that I was aware of growing up in the community.
The Hattiesburg seems in this area.
Is that true?
Does Hattiesburg have more mixed race families?
Well, I have nothing to compare it with, but we had a lot of them.
Yeah.
A lot of them, sure.
Can you tell me what it was like growing up on your, well, you had a farm, your family
farm?
Can you tell us about that?
Yes.
My dad being the youngest son and naturally involved in farming, that was his first occupation.
You know, being there within my grandfather, George, they my own several hundred acres of
land and he was a very, very successful farmer.
And having to raise 12 kids, you know, on his farm, you had to be good to feed him because
there were no public service jobs out.
And their family is really lived on mostly what they raised on the farm.
Pardon me.
Consequently, my dad, so this is just a normal way of life.
And he liked it and he became a landowner after he married my mother and my mother is
from the same community.
And my grandfather gave him a little land and a start and then he went on to go to the
inquiries on land, but there was a jaunting properties.
And my dad became successful in the business.
And early, I would say in the mid 1930s, my dad born in 1908 by that time he was like
26, 27 years old.
He bought a school bus because the days of segregated schools, the black kids had to have
transportation so the white school system loosened up and allowed independent individuals
to go buy a bus to transport black kids to and from school.
So what that did, my dad bought the school bus and that put him earning more income to
supplement the family.
So if he bought it, they would pay him to drive it?
And he leased his services in the bus to the county and they would pay him to die.
And then in the meantime, when he got the...
So he both simultaneously earned something and get his kids to school?
Right.
And not only that, by buying the bus, he had the opportunity to provide public service to
other people in the community, organizations or whatever, because during that time, we
would come now to the person that's very little personal transportation around.
So he hauled people to Sunday school conventions, church conventions, basketball games, which
supplemented his income.
And he continued to do that until 1940.
And I remember these days because at that time, I was born twenty-one, I was like eleven
years old, oldest kid, or eight kids.
You had a lot of responsibility, I imagine.
Yes, and I grew up with responsibility.
And all the farmers in the area, this whole area, they were using animals to fall.
And had not yet arrived in this area, not to any extent the work was noticeable in the
family fall.
Consequently, in 1940, the war was starting in Europe, as you well know.
And Camp Shelby is just south of here, about fifteen miles, and it was one of the major
training camps.
And it started to grow to provide what?
And it was just a war, a war, a war, a war, a war.
That created jobs because the camp had the growth to do this.
That means black folks that were living on the farm had a chance to leave the farm, not
leave the farm, go and work to supplement their farm income.
So what Dad did then, he saw an opportunity with that extra money to go and buy him a
new tractor.
So he used the income from working Camp Shelby?
No, he used the income from, he used the improvement in the economy.
Got it.
Okay.
Well, you know, to bring more money into the community, you know, and he had more activity
with what he had already gone all.
And he was using his voice to transport people to him from Camp Shelby to work and all.
So what he decided to take that extra money and bought him a tractor and all of the
implements and goes along to do his run his farm in operation.
He would have been really in the forefront of that.
He was in the forefront.
He was only guiding the neighborhood.
Why don't black out the tractor for us?
We know.
Deppin' with black folks.
And when he bought the tractor, well, other farmers in the area would use mues and horses.
And by my dad having a tractor, he could cultivate more land.
And he expanded his farm, because we used the tractor to assist all the farmers and
work that they needed, you know, to move them forward.
And then around 1942, when the war was really moving along in the black community had money
coming in, my dad said, hey, now it's time to open a grocery store.
So he opened a grocery store adjacent to the house.
He was really a very savvy business person.
He was a move in a shaker.
Only had a 10th grade education, and he'd take chances that I would have bought that.
But being raised the way he was in a progressive home, my grandfather was not opening that
progressive, but he was a move in a shaker by him having landed and had his success in
it.
And my grandfather, my dad, were very close friends to them, okay, they worked in partnership.
But by that time, my grandfather's getting up in age and the farming now is moving toward
my dad and his family, us boys.
So he's taking more responsibility.
Right.
He's taking more responsibility.
Bill is a consequent land.
They had built grocery store, a country grocery store.
And in that country grocery store, then in the black neighborhood, he also attracted some
white customers.
And the grocery store was fully equipped with everything going in canned good.
And very little electricity in that area at that time.
A lot of people living in the country had ice boxes and they used black ice for special
treats.
So he built a little ice house right next to the grocery store.
Where would he get the ice?
We bought it down at the head of the wholesale that sold it to restaurants and all.
And one of my jobs was to take that school bus and go down and hold in 300 pound blocks
ice and deliver them on a Friday and bring them and put them in ice house and chip them
into 15, 25 pound blocks.
So I could say that was one of my jobs, okay.
And being in the summertime, I didn't mind it too much.
But the ice house was built homemade.
And the salt is in the side, the insulation is in the bottom.
It was quite cool.
How did he know how to do that?
He just smart guy.
That's all I can say.
Did you help build?
No, at that time I was only about 14, 15 years old going to school.
You know my interest was like, I'm doing what I'm being told to do.
And I'm doing what I'm being told to do, too, without any question, okay.
And by being out in the forefront, I was kind of comparing, you know, boys, you know,
I'm doing this, I can drive a tractor, you can't.
Right.
And you got that time.
You find them you.
So, you know, I felt real good about who I was.
But whenever it did feel like, you know, there was never that atmosphere, you were better
than somebody else, okay.
That just never crept into the picture because I saw my family just maintaining like they
always were.
And your family talked to you all about that or was it just how they acted?
No, no, not acted.
Yeah.
You know, go to black son, go to black son in school, everything you do is black.
Right.
Say irrigation kept us what?
He kept us together.
In a way, integration really affected our unity.
You didn't have a choice before about being.
We depending on one another.
And having the same people couldn't escape it.
No, you couldn't escape it.
Now, if you step side to your bounder, you were in deep trouble.
Yeah.
Right.
And what you did to you, you learned, you didn't learn, you just comfortably in an environment
because you do nothing else.
Yeah.
So, you were going up, so you were working on the farm.
I worked on the farm.
I started all working on the farm as soon as I was making up.
And then we made the logs and chickens.
Went into the grocery business.
I learned how to cut meat.
We put it on cattle.
Most cases.
And then we, and then around 1945, now my dad had a grocery business going on.
We had a school bus business and had the farm.
And my dad is having all these boys in a row, see.
And that's good labor at that point.
Hey boy, get in house labor.
Okay.
What kind of salary were you getting?
Hey.
Sleeping boys?
Sleeping boys.
That's what Wade always looking for.
Right.
Room and board and a little spending money on a weekend, which was not very much either.
Did you get, did you have candy?
Did you get spending, penny candy at the store?
Oh, oh yeah.
Yeah.
You could do that, but you know, you had to watch it.
We were very disciplined.
Yeah.
But you still see a little bit of a reminder that the boys could be boys.
And in 1945, when the war effort was really moving, you know, in Europe and in the Pacific
area, there was more money coming into the Hattiesburg, more black folks being employed
to supplement their income.
So my dad went off and bought a saw meal, a small saw meal, because we had a lot of land,
a lot of temporal, and all.
And first he started cutting his own term.
And he had a little, had two guys that he worked with, had experience.
And then there we were.
And so we started in what?
We had dogs and cutting lumber and for sale in the neighborhood.
And the other folks heard about it first saying, I know, the lumped businesses started
in the flourish.
And dad was selling his lumber to local farmers, or whoever to build barns and chicken houses
and outhouses.
So we had three areas of income going on, okay?
When we spoke with your mother, well, Mrs. Damer, she told me that your father, you know,
knew which trees the boards came from in the house that was burned down.
Oh, yeah, yeah, sure.
When was that house built?
I was away in the military.
And it had to be built probably in the early 60s or late 50s, I don't remember.
So did you grow up in that same spot where the house is now?
Oh, yes, I grew up then.
It was a new house.
Fire bombing had destroyed, which was a new house that they were living in to when the
fire bombing took place.
So they had already had one destroyed?
Well, no.
The house I grew up was the older regional home.
That's what I was wondering about.
And then they built a new home after my dad married my stepmother, Ellen.
Okay.
But she's been in the family.
She's our mother.
Yeah.
She's been in the family of 60 or something years, okay?
She's been your mother, 60 years?
Oh, oh, yeah.
And she's a real fine lady, you know, and everything worked out fine.
My dad, Mom, they married in 1928 and they divorced about 1935.
My dad had three boys by her.
So we got three sets of kids.
Three by my mother, three by another.
The second wife, she died at 31 years old, some kind of muscular disease.
And then he married the existing mother in 1952.
I've been married then more year.
My kids are the same age.
She'll hold them in.
Then you're youngest.
So let me just ask you one more.
So in 1935, so I'm trying to, so you were about six years old.
So did you have a relationship with your mother after they divorced?
Yeah, for about two or two and a half years because her family only lived about three miles
from where we lived.
They lived all in the same community.
And my mother took the baby boy with her to live with the grandparents.
And my dad kept the two older kids my brother and I because we, he didn't have no money
to pay child support.
And Jerry's he told me to Jerry's see you keep him and feed him.
Okay.
He didn't talk about that because my mom, my mother, my maternal mother, my dad had
a beautiful relationship.
And they were heard, either what I'm talking about, or they even have to divorce.
Which I definitely appreciate when I grew up.
That makes sense.
It's not always the case.
So my mom took the baby and my dad then took us and he didn't dump us on our grandparents
who lived nearby.
I wondered.
No, he did not.
He kept us right down the house with him and then a revisit to grandparents as needed.
And he had other older ladies in the family because people jobs were for spirits.
Cheers.
Depression, 19, 28, 20, we're still in the depression.
They'd come and cook and clean and my dad would pay them or whatever.
And they were older ladies family and they'd worked out well until he married again in 1938.
And he married then and they didn't want to have three sons of my that wife.
And she died in 1949.
She had three boys.
So there we are again in the house with my dad, five boys and no mom.
And yeah.
Right.
But I grew up with that wife.
Okay.
So she was in many ways your mother?
Right.
In many ways.
One baby right after another because she was a younger woman.
She's pretty busy.
She's busy.
Yeah, but that's okay.
We are a lady in the house and it worked out fine.
Happy to have a lady in the house.
But then again, we as boys, five boys ended up then with older ladies coming in, cooking
and cleaning.
So we were raised a lot without a mother.
And our dad met the need for both.
So he was a busy man.
We were always a part of his life.
Part of his life in working, part of his life in social activities, part of his life in
play.
He never had to take out time for us.
It was just everything you did.
Everything full together.
You know, we'd work all day and go to the river out properly run adjacent to the river
and go and swim in.
He beat us in the water.
You know, he was just that kind of guy.
And I'm not making this up.
You know.
But if you talk in a mind, brothers, our dad was a focal point of our life.
Yeah.
That doesn't mean that we didn't appreciate the grandparents and the other ladies that
came through the family.
But he was his parents.
We didn't miss any fairs and the circuses and things like that.
That must have been a really remarkable childhood to the combination of the work and then
also the opportunities.
It was.
And then what that did by having, I'm this small person, by having a focus mostly on one
family person like your father who was very involved in our life.
It created an unusual unity in cooperating amongst us.
My dad was a leader.
He was a boss.
But he wasn't bossy, but he was a disciplinarian.
Consequently, we all danced by the same music, which I mean by that.
We all followed the same group of orders.
And there were no any confusion being what mom said, what dad said.
Everything coming from one direction.
And I learned this over time and raised my own kids.
Consequently, we bonded.
That's more, hey, I mean, the bond even exists today.
And I lost three brothers, you know, but if you missed with one, you missed with the whole
crowd.
But we always got along real well.
We didn't fight.
We are.
We competed, but we got along real well.
And some extent our wives think quite understood.
They couldn't compete with your brothers.
That's a fact.
But it worked out good, you know?
Yeah.
What was your schooling like going to a country school and the school was like only with
half a mile from the house, we walked school.
Did your family provide the property for the school?
Yes, my great grandfather won carely provided the property.
He gave the school, he gave one, two acres by the way to build a school building on.
And that was my grandmother, Ellen Kelly's father, Warren Kelly.
Okay.
And he was a descendant of Green Kelly, slave master, and his African mistress Sarah.
And he was a mixed race kid.
And that put him in land, you know, with family connections.
And he came out of that environment, you know, won't quite a bit of property.
And what he did, he used his property to build his first church home and the first school
and just kind of structured the community around it.
Now you had other families that came and started to build with that same attitude.
So this was not a one man show.
And he provided the land and worked with the school system.
And the first school was open in 1879, you know, school.
But prior then they had school in the church.
But that's the first school building.
Yeah, first school building, yes ma'am.
Now the first school itself came out of the church which was built was a one law cabin.
What, what denomination was it?
A shady girl, or didn't a Baptist church.
Was it built after the Civil War?
No, no, it was built in, well, the church itself was established in 1864.
Okay.
That makes sense.
The black and the Negroes and the blacks in that state and going proud of that time was
going to a white church, you probably heard it, haven't you?
Well, I don't know about this particular community, but I know it was common.
Well it didn't out community.
The whites, you know, naturally they were subjects, you know, the plantation owners.
And they went to the local Baptist church which is about four or five miles from where
I would church is.
And they obtained the church there.
And it's a providence Baptist church.
And it's still in existence also in this problem.
So is it a white church now?
That's a white church here, sure, in large church.
And then the black church members established that church, the shady girl Baptist church.
And the shady girl came from the first church service they had was on the, on the shady
tree.
Okay.
Yeah.
And the church we had it is right in the same place, the trees are all, but the church
is here.
That's too bad about the trees.
And it was a one room long cabin.
And that one room long cabin also served as the first school.
Where did the teachers come from?
Local?
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
And so when you were going, when I said local came out of family.
Yeah.
And from the beginning, from the, from when it was first founded, the first teachers were
family members from back in the 1870s.
Yeah.
Right.
And then they get their education in slavery.
Where did they get it in the immediate aftermath?
That's a good question.
That's not part of their family history.
It was, it was obvious that education in religion was the avenue.
Out of slavery.
Because the first thing you're going to do is build a church.
And the second thing you're going to do as a free slave is to build a school.
You learn something from being what enslaved.
Because you saw that going on around you.
So rather than go out and you know, do something differently, what you do is you repeat
what you've already seen.
Yeah.
Even though you may not have been a part of the building, you were part of what, of
the success.
Yeah.
You know what freedom?
Right.
And then when my grandfather, my great grandfather, Warren Kelly, he educated his kids.
Yeah.
And when my grandfather, George Daimler, Warren, to Mary Ellen, oh, where's your education?
And he would not, he would not permit it until what?
Until my grandfather went to Jackson State and improved his education.
That's where my grandmother, the Ellen Kelly had gone.
Okay.
So there was enough education at that time coming right out of slavery, okay?
Well, let's put it was enough forethought about education that provided people who
had enough to teach.
Well, there were always people that found ways to learn.
Found ways to learn, right?
Right.
Even when there was a law saying you couldn't.
So your grandfather, George Daimler, went to Jackson State for a while?
Yes, he did.
Okay.
And your father went through 10th grade.
And he went through 10th grade in a local commuter school, in the base spring school.
That was probably the last grade they had.
At that time it was the last grade and there's a population increase and decrease.
They would go from 10 to 12, back to 10 to 12.
And at the time, my dad was going to his 10th grade.
By the time my graduate, 1948, it was 12th grade.
So what was, so you said that you went to the school about a half mile from your home?
Yes.
And what was that school like?
Being in the commuter for you knew a lot of the kids, practiced all of the kids, except
the ones that may be in outlying areas.
It was, it was more like a big family reunion.
You knew everybody and there was a lot of fun.
And you never felt out of place.
And the teachers that we had blended right into that same environment.
And it was, it was a good atmosphere for learning.
Because the education I have, the basic education, what it is and what you see and what you hear
started right there.
And coming out of a family, many other black families too, by the way, you know, they came
prepared to learn.
And my dad always had a saying a lot of the older guys and I read the kids say, hey, I'm
not sending you to school to carry a lunch.
But we didn't have lunch room.
Hey, I got working at the house for you to do.
So going to school served two purposes.
Again, the education, plus get out a lot of hard work.
Okay.
So then it didn't lack a lot of motivation.
You didn't think a lot of motivating to do it.
Okay.
And a whole lot of the kids, their families were not able to continue their education.
We had a lot of dropouts.
And that was the, as I looked back, that was the sad thing.
For my family and there was other families, you know, allowing their kids to go on through
and graduate.
All of us graduated from high school.
Yeah.
No, I know that I've had many people tell me that they had to work so they couldn't
keep going.
And I saw that we got, you got to the fourth grade.
By the time you meet to the fifth, the kids big enough to go to the fields and work, you
start losing population.
And by the time you got to the tenth of the eleventh grade, my class only had eight people
at it.
Yeah.
And we started off with a big class, you know, in the primary.
What were your favorite subjects?
I like math.
I like reading.
And math and reading.
English had difficulty with because I could never grasp the verb and the noun and the
pronoun.
I could do those, but when you got over to the other parts, the subjunctive.
Yeah.
Whatever that is.
And I kind of tuned it out because I figured I didn't need it anyway.
I found out later that I did.
And so I had to go back and do some remedial study to move ahead.
You didn't see any need for it.
But those were my favorite and favorite subjects.
And then later on, when I said later on, when I got to being about the fifth or sixth
grade, we had a spelling class when the kids get up before the class and the teacher would
call your word and you spell it.
I fell in love with spelling.
And the way it happened was my dad drove a school bus and when he come to pick up the kids,
the spelling was the last class at the end of the day.
And he'd become to my classroom.
And here I am up at the board, writing my spelling letters that the teacher would call
them out.
And my dad's watching me misspeel these words.
Okay.
So when we get home at night, he says, get the spelling book.
And we sit down in front of the fireplace, Kerosene lamp.
And he called me those words.
And if I miss one, he bumped me upside the head.
And after a while, you know, I got where I learned, and then I learned how to what.
Identify syllables.
And then I do pretty well at that.
And so that turned out to be helped a lot.
Was it, did you enjoy doing that with your dad or was it pressure?
No, I didn't enjoy it.
I didn't bump up so I did, you know.
You have to learn how to act under pressure if you're going to do it.
That's exactly right.
So, but all in all the school turned out well, graduated, you know, on time, 18 years
old.
I've talked to a few people.
I think they're a little younger than you and they went to different schools.
But one person was telling me that she had a, she didn't call it civics class.
I can't remember what she called it, but she said that the teacher actually talked to
them about voting in their class.
Did you ever have any kind of, yes, yes, I don't want to miss that piece.
Our principal was progressive.
He was educated.
He saw, he saw the need for education and, that was my thought.
I asked you about voting teachers.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
He saw the need for the education and he was really in tune with African American history,
Negro history.
I learned about Book of T. Washington, you know, early in the stage.
George Washington, Carver, the Underground Railroad.
And all of those things I learned right there in the 1940s.
We had a little thin, green, black history book and I went looking for one when I returned
home and it identified the prominent Negroes back in that day.
Then that it really made a difference in bringing us forward as far as education is concerned.
And I tried to find it and he acquired that book and then we had to, it was a part of
the curriculum.
It's seventh and eighth grade.
So I had a real good feel of what blacks had done up that period.
You're invented to cotton gin and things that came along in the era, okay?
Did you have any sense of the politics behind that?
No.
Because, of course, the white school district, you know, the white school district, you
know, the white, you know, I imagine that your school had a black principal and then probably
a white superintendent or something.
White superintendent.
And the most of our textbooks came from the white schools because they passed, they used
textbooks down to the black schools.
Right.
Some of them have pages missing.
You see names of other kids, you know, but they were books.
Did you think about that at the time that you're getting these second handbooks or anything?
No, I didn't.
Did you have any sense of the white kids school or did you have any contact with them?
The white school was only about two and a half, three miles away and they lived in another
world.
But now, their property that joined ours, we would see them.
We knew them.
But we went to separate schools.
Everything was separate.
Separate churches schools, you know, separate theaters when you went to town and we went
to have a chance to go to the movie.
You know, we didn't have any social interaction.
Or maybe we didn't have a creek swimming, you know, on a hot summer day and played just
like nothing ever happened.
I grew up with them.
But we didn't, socially we didn't, we didn't mix outside of that.
I know you said that your dad's store had white customers.
And white customers?
Did he ever have white people working on the land?
Yes.
There were some poor in the community that were just so poor that they would come and
they'd work in the cotton fields.
Pick cotton.
And I do remember they wouldn't be in mixed up.
They'd like maybe a part of the field but not the distance away.
Little segment here, blacks and little segment there, all a journey, picking cotton together.
Yeah.
Right.
But now they were extremely poor white folks to do that.
They really, that they would have to have a pretty desperate need and order.
Very desperate need.
Very desperate need, yes.
Yeah.
But we didn't look at them as being poor just some white folks, you know, come pick cotton.
I mean, when you were working in the store or when your dad had the store, were there
ever any issues with white customers or did things go pretty good?
My dad had had not malicious, you know, not our organ and that.
And white customers coming take his goods and we didn't pay him because my dad could
not make them pay.
Okay.
Back in that day people didn't walk around with credit cards, they cash them in the
park and they buy groceries and put them on a charge book.
And when they got paid to come pay the bill and buy more stuff.
And they living from week to week, a pay to pay the pay date.
Well, some of the white customers took advantage of my dad like that.
And I was one guy right after the war came back and he was a vet and he got in good with
my dad and he was paying his bill real well.
My dad didn't get too far out and he owed my dad several hundred dollars and walked
off.
And by that time I'm working in the grocery store, you know, my clerk cutting meat, selling
ice, you know, pumping gas, fixing flats, whatever.
And I was in tune with what was going on in the business and my dad had a good business
on them, Sarah, then when the country folks come by, you know, to buy, or he, money was
ever not in, we had a lot of money.
And actually you had to put it back into the business.
But the business was good and growing and you had them to do that.
What would your dad say anything about that?
Did he talk to you or did he?
No, he didn't say that.
He just, we had no distractions like television.
There was a lot of family conversation that went on in the presence of the kid and my
dad was open and he says, yeah, I'm saying, I'm having this number on, and he won't pay
me.
And I, and he'd be disappointed and they need to move on.
Okay.
And on the, on the other hand, I saw my dad and I was a part of this.
There was some families there, primarily black.
Not very many, but so poor, they'd come to buy groceries and then have enough and they
have kids.
And when they were driving the store, they'd sit on the, you saw the picture of the store,
sit on the porch, my dad had given them a drink and a moon pie.
And that was their treat.
Walked up there, you know, from way back in the woods, some place.
And then when they, before they got rid of it, to leave, they'd have a little grocery
list.
Most of them had the grandmother or somebody like that.
He'd give them extra meat, just pass out and stuff.
And he just had open heart.
And he got that from his dad.
Excuse me.
No, I imagine that's something you never, never lose.
No.
He got that from, from George Damour.
My grandfather, George Damour, had enough property to where he had sharecroppers.
You probably heard that.
And only a couple of families, but they were not servants.
They'd people coming in looking for, for making a living.
They'd come from other communities.
And he had a couple of little houses, you know, nothing, nobody had nothing fancy.
And they'd move in.
And what we made, you know, as far as edibles, greens, peas, you even had sugar cane, made
on certain all that.
They were like a family, they participated in it.
Nobody went hungry.
It was a more communal kind of thing.
It was right.
But you maintain your independence and you will respect it as an individual.
And there was a love relationship in that environment.
Because those people appreciated so much until they loved him.
And they give them all, he loved them back likewise, by the way.
Never looked down, wasn't a noisy man, quiet.
And we just, we killed four, five hogs and help people come help us clean the hog and
he'd be passing.
Not pass, not they could take what they want them we share.
Now that sharing came out of that, to me, as I looked back on it and as a kid growing,
it came out of that slave type community where we had to depend on one another.
And we knew that was the way we had to make it.
And it carried right on over beyond that period.
And it went right on into what the way my grandfather treated everyone and my dad was raised
with it.
And that's part of life.
You know what?
We do the same thing.
I just did something that was pretty crazy about a young, I'm involved in the skylts,
hip and kids and all this.
I'm not bringing anything.
And kids, dad died and his mother died.
He was small, living the community raised up there.
And his dad was an older guy and a dad died and left him a little house and ate our land.
And the kid, you know, he's 19 years old.
He had paid tax on what tax collector came on, took the property.
The property is a join in my property that I owned.
They said, do you want a bad?
Not look at him and say, to my own safe not on bad.
Yeah.
I go to tax collector.
I say, how much does this cost?
What did this guy pay for?
You know, that boy did tax, he only told me.
My relationship, our relationship, so good with his citizens in this area.
He told me everything.
He said, tell you what, Bernie, and he said, call him.
Tell him you talk to me.
And the pay property is paid a little house on it for $15,000.
Well, he ain't got no $15,000.
But I got to get out and eat for $950.
Okay?
So what did I do?
Pardon me.
My son is a bit in favor.
So I got in contact with the guy and then this investor said,
well, I financed, I said, no, we'll take care of that.
I've seen him a check for $950.
Now, I'm not wealthy.
$950, a lot of money to me.
But in the meantime, I said, this kid was raised up in a environment where people
lived and he had no real guidance.
I was not known.
It was not good enough for him to survive on his own.
And so what?
I got all the people who were fixed up, made him a payment plan.
He's going to give me back in a year.
And I show him how to pay your taxes, how to get the home state exemption,
train like I train my kids.
And when I finished with him the other day, and got him all set up.
And he works for my brother Dennis that you sell there, doing the sugar cane thing.
Cut my mom's yard.
OK.
Hey, we don't throw you away.
And he's going to do all right.
He left the house, and my wife had some chicken.
He went out to have a tear scene.
I bet he did.
Yeah.
But then he lost his family.
And he has to have a son.
I didn't go out to the community.
I'd say, you are.
That's not the publication.
I understand.
No, that's what we do.
Yeah.
Sure.
And Claiborne County, there was a man that had land.
You have to keep me on track.
No, no, you're good.
And he wanted people to have houses.
And so he sold people land at a price they couldn't have bought it anywhere else.
They call it Jones Village out there now after him.
He's that right?
That's right.
Where is that at?
It's in Claiborne County.
Yeah, my doctor's been over there.
Yeah.
He passed away.
So when you graduated from high school, what did you do next?
I enrolled in Tugaloo.
Yeah.
Tugaloo is expensive.
Okay, but my cousin was going there and his mother was a teacher.
Yeah.
He could afford it.
But I went anyway.
And I went to Tugaloo and during the very first semester, I became serious for you.
We do more for testing time.
And I was unable to take my test.
My dad had to come get me.
And by the time I recovered, we'd already gone into another semester.
So I stayed at home.
My 18 years old at that time, gone on 19.
And I'm a part of the workforce.
So I went to work for the remainder of the year and then in the next school year, I went
to all corn.
Yeah.
And when I got out to all corn, then the second wife, she took seriously ill.
And then I had to come home and help in the business because things were not going
good after World War II.
She was in her recession.
In the early 50s, and I came home to help my dad and reburied her.
And then I went back to all corn again.
And by the time I lost my department, and that's when the draft came, we got it.
So that ended my education.
But I had a full year.
A full year?
Yeah.
I had 38 credits.
Oh, that's about it, didn't it?
You see, I mean, 30 years.
What's about three semesters?
Let's see, 38 credits, 13 classes.
Yeah.
Did you like, well, tell me what all corn was like?
All corn.
I went there under the work program.
And a lot of country kids, a lot of kids from the country.
And then there were some kids there from upper class, back family, and still you know,
didn't want to dress there every day.
And then that was us kids.
And we came out of the country.
So there was some adapting to do to that environment.
And some of them came out of some schools.
Well, they came out of famous work.
They were probably advanced in their education, educational abilities now.
But all in all, it was a big, big thing back in the woods.
And there were very few distractions, very few.
Counting crickets.
That's exactly right.
And it was all about work, study, and sports.
And I was not qualified to be on any of the teams.
Just go to some of them.
And that was the extent of it.
Very little time for girls.
Not all the nun.
Not only that they had a missus there, they missed town.
She'd kill you.
Yeah, they had some strict rules, didn't they?
It's very strict rules.
You walked a girl to the dumb hole in my hand, which didn't happen very often anyway.
And when you got to the dumb, that didn't do that.
No kissing, no hooking on it.
You better get from here.
And a curfew too, probably, for the girls.
Not a good curfew.
Was it for you too, or for just for the girls?
Oh, it says for the girls, I would imagine.
They were well, I don't know what could they have.
We didn't like that much stiffening classroom.
Yeah.
Was there a big difference between two glue and all corn?
More fluid kids.
Definitely more fluid.
You could see it.
And it was obvious.
Yeah, I was more comfortable at all corn.
Sure.
Because I had more guys from rural communities
farming and had a lot more in common and being in a work program.
And all corn was an agricultural school.
And it was an agricultural school.
And I was majoring in agriculture that was my goal.
So that probably influenced?
Then that, right.
It did influence.
Most of my parents worked in a dairy because at that time,
we had our own dairy, our own cattle.
And I had a job inside mopping full of them.
Which was good, I liked it.
When we were talking before we started taping,
you mentioned about two glue having white faculty.
Yes, it did.
What was that like for you?
Did you think about it?
It, I was not overwhelmed by it because coming out of a community
where there were a lot of light skinned people, there was not
this contrast of dark white.
Because I came out of a family in a community
where there were just a lot of lights in folks.
And the whites in our neighborhood,
they had acted also.
So no.
But it did surprise me to have white instructors
with all the black students.
And that may have been a handful of white students
at that time, if I remember correctly, it's kind of hard to tell.
And the president was president Warren.
And I think he was handicapped.
I think he was.
I don't really know much about two right at that time.
And a couple of my teachers were one of my know was white.
Yeah.
Were they from other parts of the country?
Or were they local?
I don't know.
You don't know.
No, man.
I had meant to ask you before, was your father
registered to vote when you were younger?
No.
Was he ever able to register?
I know some people were registered.
And then they took them off the rolls.
And then they had to try to re-register.
No.
My dad was very conscious of the fact
that he was being denied the same opportunity as whites.
And he didn't hide that from us.
He didn't.
He depended on them for survival.
And he never did talk mean about them.
But he let us know that there was a difference in survival.
And he would tell us, boys, he said, you got to be twice as good
to stay out of trouble.
You got to work twice as hard to get ahead.
It's not even.
And he let you know that upfront, it is not even.
And that helped a lot when I went in the air force.
Because I felt a little inferior.
Because I think the white kids went out of these superior
schools.
But after a while, I found out, well, yeah, they
made a came out of superior institution.
But someone was smarter than me.
Oh, kids.
But anyway, at least I didn't think there were any way.
So I lost my thought.
Well, I had asked you about your dad trying to vote.
Oh, yeah.
So in growing up in that environment,
my dad paid very close attention to what was going on around
him, like my grandfather.
He had newspaper every day.
We didn't have electricity in the house
until I was probably in the eighth grade.
And we stood by light.
And my dad bought a small radio, RCA,
one of the old-fashioned kind.
And so he could listen to the news in other programs.
And he would drive the school bus up to the window of the house
and drew the power from the truck battery to run the radio.
And that's how he'd listen to radio.
And there were three things that he'd listen to religiously.
One up in the evenings, at 6 o'clock news,
with John Cameron Swasey.
Because he'd make us sit down and be quiet and hear the news.
If you want to change that, so just let me know.
OK.
And everybody, the news is on.
He didn't have to tell you.
News on, you be quiet and you listen.
You didn't leave the room.
He listened to Loman Abna.
They came on every day if you ever heard a Loman Abna.
OK, that was a comedy show of Hillbillies.
They came on every day on the Loman Abna,
and then the jot them down store in the country.
Yeah.
And Amos and Andy at 6 o'clock in evening.
And on a Saturday night, he would listen to the grand old
opera.
So that was the big entertainment?
That big entertainment.
So you got news?
Right.
And a couple of shows.
But as resolved, or paying attention in keeping up with the news,
we all became news listeners.
OK.
Influence.
And we found out that's where you get your information from.
My dad had another saying, once we got
beaten up on the sandwich, talking about,
he said, pay attention to what's going on around you.
And you have a chance to get away without being
a victim of your search circumstances.
In other words, don't be a victim of your environment
because you're not paying attention.
Then he had a parable he used.
Don't be like a hog eating acres on a big oak tree.
You eat an acreage, but you never look up
to see where they are coming from.
And then when the acres run out and you're hungry,
you left the stop to death.
So be aware what's going on around you.
And that's just where we all grew up.
All of us are very political oriented, OK?
Very much so.
So we came up in a political environment.
So when in the mid 1940s, my dad had heard about the NAACP
started up, OK?
And he and eight other black men
established the farest-counter branch of the NAACP.
It was nine of them that started it.
And they held secret meetings.
And they went to the meetings at night.
The nine black men in the Hattensperf area
that founded the farest-counter branch of the NAACP.
And it was around 1945, the mid 1940s, OK?
And at that time, they had the meetings at night.
And my dad would always let us know, let me know.
I'm going to NAACP meeting because it
was an underground type organization on that time.
And he continued to go to these meetings very religiously.
And then when he go to the meeting, he would come home
and we'd be working there.
And he'd tell us, tell me and my whole brother
what was going on as we did our work, all right?
And as a result of him being a part of that organization,
and he let us know by just a conversation
that there was, it had something to do with politics.
OK?
It had something to do with voting, OK?
So in about 1946, yeah, I think I was around 16, 17 years old, maybe.
My dad started taking me with him even before then when he did business.
I'd go with him when he paid the property tax.
And at the same time, you paid the property tax to the sheriff.
Sheriff was a tax collector in Faris County.
He would also pay his poll tax.
And when he leave the sheriff's office,
he'd go down the hall to the voter registration office
and pay his poll tax.
Well, on this one occasion, he went to pay the poll tax.
And may have been the first, I don't know what happened, proud to then.
He went then.
He pulled out his receipt.
He had his hand.
And there was this white man behind the counter.
And he walked up me asking, I knew who my dad was, I don't know, being a country town.
Yeah, what do you want?
That's how I paid my poll tax.
I want to register.
And he looked at him.
It's just kind of like staring at him, you know, why are you here?
I remember that because I'm old enough not to know how you treat my dad.
And he gave my dad a card, like a full-baked card, a six-bate, and he had some writing on it.
He said, read that and tell me what to say.
And then he went on back and said, I'm.
My dad read the information on the card.
And finally, he says, sir, I'm finished.
And the guy came up and looked at him and looked at him.
He said, all right, tell me what you read.
My dad told him.
He says that's not what he said.
And that was end of it.
Now, here's a man, my father, who had helped me with my lesson.
He was in business.
He was running a business.
And he couldn't interpret what was on the card.
Now, I was old enough to know that's not true.
That aggravated me so.
Because what you did, you just denied a man that I cared a lot about.
Hey, you just told him, you don't know what you're talking about.
That didn't hit me very well.
Now, I didn't get mad about it, but I saw that as strange because I'd never seen this up front that close.
I'm sure it's happened other places.
And from that time on, he may have continued.
I didn't go with him anymore, but I don't know what he did or did not.
And the next time I heard anything about him becoming involved was when he became president
of the local NAACB during the mid-50s.
And as a result of the Supreme Court ruling on the school segregation problem, I was at
Brown versus Board Education in Kansas.
Something like that.
I think that's right.
Mississippi then tightened up.
It really tightened up.
Hey, we're not going to have no school integration here.
My days already involved in the NAACB by then.
And he's out of the closet.
The organization is out of the closet.
It's well known.
And then that's when he became targeted by the hostile forces out there.
What is that first incident that you saw or the one that you witnessed?
Did he say anything to you when you were riding home that day?
Did he say anything to you?
Did he talk to you about what happened?
No, he did not.
No.
I think, going that time, I can only think that that was such a routine practice of being
denied.
Maybe he would not be there to him, so maybe he'd go with other blacks.
He just suck it up and move on.
Yeah.
And you said when he was president in the mid-1950s, people knew who he was.
Oh, yeah, without a doubt.
And you said that's when the harassment started.
Yeah.
That's when the harassment started then, okay?
Do what?
You probably weren't hard on him.
I wasn't here, but he told you about it.
Yeah, he talked about it.
Can you tell us what he said to you or what you know about it?
Yeah.
That's the first time, you know, the racial climate was changing.
You know, the tension was rising.
And this friendly atmosphere that we once had there was disappearing.
Now he is how I experienced it.
I went in Air Force 1951.
I came home around 1955 at that time after I had re-enlisted and chose Air Force as a
career.
And I was a staff sergeant, did well during my first investment.
And I stopped at the local white grocery store that had been in the community before
my dead bill, too, because we had a relationship with that family, because that's where we did
our trading.
And I stopped there to get some gas.
Now I went in with a real friendly atmosphere and the wife of the store owner, she
was there and I spoke to her and they had one son and he was several years younger than
me, but I saw him grow up.
So I asked her, I said, well, where is your son?
I called him by his name and she said, you mean Mr.
Someone's Son?
Well, here I am now 25 years old, 26.
And she want me to call us on who's probably still a teenager, Mr. Never saw that before.
And I stopped at another grocery store in the community on down, coming toward Hattiesburg
where we would stop occasionally.
And I went in there just to buy something because I feel comfortable being at home and
the grocery store owner there, he said, oh, you're in there?
You're up now, and I said, yes I am.
I was stationed in Nebraska, Omaha, and off of Air Force Base.
And he says, what's it like being up there?
Okay?
Are they different?
Okay.
So he was quizzing me on my being outside of that in Mississippi environment.
Have you been growing?
And how had it affected me being in a more integrated area?
And I picked up on that immediately.
He was wanting to know if you've been ruined or not.
I'd been ruined, that's exactly right.
So that's how I knew then that the things had changed and my dad was getting into a situation.
But I didn't really focus on it because it had not been any open violence.
It was just a rise in the recognition that things about to happen in Mississippi now that
the mass does not want to happen.
And you're not going to be treated quite as kindly and as friendly as it was because
now you're starting to threaten our way of life.
And I had to look back on it.
I didn't recognize it at that time.
So what I did then was I didn't go into these places.
I just kind of stayed away from them.
Yeah.
Did your father talk to you about the changing atmosphere?
Did you just know it from your own experience?
When I would visit home, he didn't have to say it.
He was obvious.
Yeah.
And I was obvious.
He would, for example, I came home with my family at that time because I had a couple of kids
and we stayed there with him.
And he says, hey, be careful where you go and you hear.
At night time, we don't walk and get in front of windows.
And also we've seen some harassment here.
There was a gun in that room where you're going to be.
If you hear anything, hey, be aware of it.
Well, being military, that was a big deal.
Come out of the family, we had guns.
Hey, that's okay.
I'm comfortable with that environment.
So I saw the difference happening then.
It's a real change to have to take all those precautions.
They have to take all those precautions.
That is exactly right.
Sure.
Can you tell me about your own military experience?
What happened when you got drafted?
What I happened when I got drafted was it was doing the height of the Korean War.
And there was troops everywhere.
And when I'm in my everywhere, you know,
when you get into that military environment.
And I left home on a bus and went to Jackson along with some other recruits.
Went to the recruiting stand, at the reporting place.
And it was on a tri-state bus, a great one, on the other.
And there were whites and black guys on there.
And maybe some other passengers don't remember exactly.
But we got there and checked in.
The day was far along.
They gave us some food and took us to Motel.
Well, there was no Motel for whites.
We went out on Ferris Street.
That was a black hotel down there, okay?
Well, I'd been on Ferris Street, so, yeah, I'm all right.
We're free.
And the white ones, they went.
And the next morning got up and they picked us up in the bus and
scared us to the induction center.
And that's when the processing took place, you know,
along stripping down, doing your physicals and all.
And getting rid of the ship us off.
From there, the next day, we left, no,
we ended up with the San Antonio, Texas.
The lack of an Air Force base, which is a major Air Force training base.
And now I mean, there were troops all over the place.
And we were sleeping in tents because the permanent structures were all full.
And I'm gonna stay there just about three weeks.
And they keep us busy, guys busy.
Most of what got up, dressed, do your military thing.
And they've got and picked up big rocks, put them on pile.
And then the next day we'd come along and we'd pick up the smaller ones,
put them in piles, okay?
Let's keep it busy.
You thought I'm kidding, that's a fact.
All right, and then during the night, they spread them all out again and whatever.
All right.
But anyway, you went through all that stuff, you know,
my mom and my 22 years old, been working on the fall.
Yeah, I'm not yet picking up rocks.
And then we went on a ship,
this out there, a ship with Air Force base in Wichita Falls, Texas.
That's why I did my basic training.
From basic training, I was assigned to French and Seymour and Air Base
in Cheyenne, Wyoming, for my tech training.
And that was a tele-type training school there,
along with other training facilities too,
for in the communications field.
And there was a motor transportation and bigot,
then kids had to drive trucks and stuff.
Let me ask you, so how did you feel about being drafted?
I tried to try my best day out of it.
My dad tried to get me deferred.
And I didn't want to go.
No, I did not want to go.
All because I'm comfortable where I am.
Yeah.
What about were you drafted specifically into the Air Force?
Or did you have any say?
Oh, that's the piece I missed.
No, let me tell you how that happened.
All right.
One, there may be a little month, a little over,
proud to going in the Air Force.
I received a letter from the,
that'll name, Local Boy.
The draft boy?
Brack Boy.
Directing the I report for induction
on the 15th of September, 1951.
And I looked at it and I said,
okay, well, I'm getting ready to get out of here.
So I'm living in the house of my dad,
and I told him, hey, this is what this is about.
So I start preparing to go off to the Army.
Because that's where the guys were going, right?
My uncle, my dad's baby sister's husband
was in the 92nd Infantry in Italy,
a ground foot soldier, fault.
And I told him, he said, no, no, you don't want to do that.
Uh-oh.
Then I had a couple of other black guys in the community
that was in combat, he said, you don't want to do that.
He said, hey, go to the Navy or the Air Force.
Don't get caught up in this Army thing.
And after they told me that, I said, okay.
So I procrastinated up until the 10th of September.
You didn't give yourself much?
No.
And I said, look, I got to make up a man.
So I went to the Air Force Recruiter.
He enhanced bird is in the basement of the old post office,
downtown, yeah.
And I walked in and there was an Air Force Recruiter,
armor recruiter, Navy Recruiter.
I'm not sure whether they had a Marine or not.
And I saw the Air Force not winning that door.
And that sergeancy said, can I help you?
Now, I told him, I said, I like to volunteer for the Air Force.
So he gave me some papers that fell out and, you know,
and I took some tests of whatever.
And he said, well, when you want to leave,
I said, can I leave today?
He said, no, the bus is already gone.
He said, we're about in the morning,
be down here at seven o'clock.
I said, OK, I'll be here.
So at seven o'clock, I reported to the post office,
and they were there and they carried us down to the bus station,
which is they all walked north street, you know,
called a bus out the Jackson.
And so after I got situated at Shepherd Air Force Base
in basic training, which is in Wichita Falls, Texas.
And that was it, by the way, in the early part of September
of 1951, I was in my unit and my squad drilling with them
out on the parade field going through my training.
And in that group, we must have been about 30 guys
in these squads.
My name came out over the PA system,
private Vernon, Dameron, Jr. report to the order room.
I'm 22 years old.
I'm in there with a bunch of guys, not 18, 19, maybe 20.
I'm kind of like the old dude, OK?
Never a few left over in World War II.
You know, that was coming back again.
And but not very many.
I don't know if it was one of them out, but anyway, I was
saying, what have I done now?
Because I'm in this middle-aged environment now.
Your name come out.
You don't remember anything that you did.
What have I done?
Right.
And so squadly to call to a hall.
This miss me from the group told me report to the order room.
I went to the order room, reported to the first sergeant.
He's two gentlemen.
I won't talk with you.
They went to me in clothes.
And they asked me, your name?
I told them burn up, they were junior.
Let me see your dog tags.
Dog tags, romma, they put them in dog tags out.
And they checked them.
That's who you are.
He said, you know your draft Dodger.
No sir.
I didn't know that.
Well, didn't you get your notice from the local board?
Lion's room and team.
No sir.
I didn't sign for it.
Lion stood in flat foot.
And he said, well, they sent you one.
I said, no sir, I never got it.
He said, well, OK.
You already in now.
I guess that's all right.
Well, I guess it is all right.
You're going to take me out and put me in the army?
I wasn't thinking that for him.
I'm thinking that now.
And when we did that, well, the press variation dried up.
And I got a hold of my nerves.
And the first sergeant said, all right, get back to your unit.
I went back to my unit.
Did you know that that might happen?
Or did you just know that was going to happen?
No.
And then he just flashed the badges on me.
So they were from some kind of investigative unit.
I don't know whether with the FBI or the local arm
investigators, you know, their own investigators.
But no, they were federal.
I know that though.
They had a federal.
That's a little nerve-wracking.
Would all of them.
And you came up with that?
On your feet.
Oh my.
You don't be in 22 years old.
You learn how to lie.
You learn how to lie quick.
Especially when you get in the band.
It sounds like it came in handy.
Yes, it is.
That's a good skill.
I guess.
Yeah, very good.
It worked.
When you went into the military, how did you end up?
You said you went to the communication school for teletype training.
How did that come about?
That's another phase that's very interesting.
I was assigned to Fransity One Air Base in Chiang Wai-Homie and to become a teletype operator.
Being raised on a farm, or we had an old cash register.
My dad found somewhere and it was manual.
And now you're taking this farm, boy, who's going to use the drive in trucks, hauling logs,
running tractor and all this.
Yes, I had mechanical abilities, operation type, operating type abilities, but not for no
typewriter, no teletype.
Yeah.
No typewriter.
And they assigned me that school and I started off and after that for a while, I was in this
typing class, J-U-G-S-F-G-F-S-F.
And I'm telling myself I don't want to be in a teletype operator.
This doesn't fit me in my prior experience.
And across this great big open field while I'm in big and everything is open, was a bunch
of guys in training learning how to drive a truck with a trailer.
I knew how to do that.
I got back a truckload of Lumber Donald alley.
And I'm sitting there in front of a typewriter and I can go to that just school and I can
go right through that and build truck driver.
And I want to have to deal with this typewriter.
Well being the old-against community in my squadron, I had a relationship somehow with the
first sergeant.
You know, been around a little bit.
And I started to be his runner.
He asked me, he said, Damour, I need guys that carry messages from one outfit to another
to the headquarters.
You want to do that?
That's doing my off time when I got off in the evening, okay?
Well I'm doing this remedial training, me and two other guys trying to catch up in the
typing.
And then I would do that, you know, my off time, thinking I made a little something out
of that.
So doing that, time I was working with the first sergeant, things got real comfortable
with my sergeant.
I said, can I go in and talk to the captain?
I want to go to the old here, is that that automotive training place to the truck driving
school.
And he said, man, they don't need you doing that, you're intelligent.
Finally, which is one day, he said, okay, he made a appointment with me to see the captain.
And I got all dressed up and went in and reported to the captain and gave him my experience
in old driving truck, raised on the farm.
And he said, and I know with this nice little smile on his face.
And I thought I was getting over on him.
And when I finished, he says, you know what, you got a lot of good experience.
And they can use you over there.
He said, but private, they might.
He says, the Air Force needs come first.
And I want you to go back down to that teletype school and be the best teletype operator in
the outfit.
And I'm going to burst into my bubble right in front of his desk.
And when I went by the first sergeant, he said, I told you so.
I went on back to the barracks and I got with it.
It resigned yourself?
Yes, I did.
I learned how to type, graduated, and believe it or not, that was the best decision that
was made for me by somebody else.
That being a teletype operator moved me into the communications vein all the way to
computers when I retired as a senior master sergeant.
That ain't no way I would have been a senior master sergeant driving a truck.
And I got promoted on my first enlistment because I was used to what, studying, I was
used to commitment.
So I didn't have no problem becoming a good title type operator.
And it worked out real well.
And I married two, one month before I went into Air Force.
And by the time I finished my first enlistment at Tendell Air Force Base in Florida, where
I was stationed, I was already a staff sergeant.
I could take my family with me any place I went.
And then assignment came up going to Europe.
But proud to my first assignment, let me back up a moment.
When I got out of Tendell Type School, my first assignment then was to a radar station
in Omaha, Nebraska.
Not today I was at a radar station.
From there to Omaha, Alaska, a radar site, overlooking the Siberian streets, watching
the Russians take off and land every day.
They fly out and they leave you there for a year.
Wow, isolated.
I married one month before I leave.
My wife is pregnant with a baby.
I'm wanting to be home and I'm sitting here now in this isolated place waiting for a year
to pass.
I must have been a...
To me it was domesticated, purified, or whatever.
But it was all work.
Now, that's new.
You work in SLL.
And I cleaned up extra work in the office of the quarter to make extra money sent to my
wife and all.
So when I came, when I was a sign from there, I had preference on the base because of
this...
Because of where you lived in?
Where'd been.
And I picked Panama City, Florida, which was close to home.
And then your wife was able to be with you?
And my wife came down there with me.
I wanted to have two strikes.
She came down, but the headquarters on base for Lil' Rican Airmen.
And by that time, I had two kids born and girl.
They were little kids.
And I went there with two strikes and I stayed there in May too, while I was there.
And worked out well and I re-enlisted and started my Air Force career.
So at re-enlistment time, I talked to my wife and said, look, now proud of talking with
my wife, this worn off from Kentucky, White fellow.
World War II was my boss.
He was a communications officer over the whole thing.
And I had left the comm center being a touch tape operator here and I was just clerk.
I'm going to type on a tight rail then, okay?
That's why I got my right working for him.
He jacked me up, but I had to work though.
Now I became a Western Union accountant clerk where I was doing all the tasks.
And he said, he said, sorry, Damon, you come off a re-enlistment, but I talk about it.
He said, what's your gun do?
I said, well, I'm going back to Mississippi.
To my dad, you know, he saw me on the issue.
He said, you're crazy.
He said, you only got 16 years to go.
Well, you're already a status sergeant.
So let me ask you, I don't know if I know enough about the military.
So was your draft two years or four years?
It was four years, two.
It was a four year tour.
Four years, four years tour.
So, okay.
So once you moved towards the air force, you had to have it longer tour.
Two more years.
All right.
So you had invested four years.
I invested four years, but that gave me a chance to make enough right to where I can
make a decision when I want to become a career in hindsight.
And so that was enough for you to envision a career with the Air Force.
And then when I told my boss, because his office is like that.
And I'm in here, tight right, and I'm supposed to do this other work.
He said, you're crazy.
And he and the top sergeant in the outfit that who's in the office with him coming
to say, you don't want to do that.
Hey, I started explaining the Air Force benefits and then I got things going on, which I hadn't
really zeroed in on.
And so after I talked with my wife and told them about it, and I said, yeah, I'm real
this.
And I went back and I told them and said, yeah, Mr. He's one of them.
And I said, Mr. Just, yes, I'm realist.
He made a appointment.
And I went on to talk to the commanding officer, squadron, leader, major.
And he already received notification that I was going to reenlist.
And I walked in.
He shook me.
He said, hey, Mr. Johnson, say you're going to reenlist.
I said, yes, I'm going to do.
He said, congratulations.
Then they sent me off a reenlistment.
Okay.
And they were giving me a bonus for reenlisting.
Yeah.
And if you reenlist for four years, you get a certain amount.
If you reenlist for six years, you get more money.
Well, since I'm going, I went for six years.
And when I went to the finance office, they paid us in cash.
I had a stack of $20 bills that high.
That's most money I've been sitting my life.
And I said, oh, man, so you felt like you made a good decision.
Oh, I went on to my wife, I was rich.
So she lived there on beach, you know.
And had bought me a little forward car.
Yeah.
And everything was going well.
And that started my Air Force career.
And the house was fire bombed in 1966.
In 1964, my family and I had returned from Germany.
And obviously, we'd been dead and my mom there in the family home.
And my wife is from here also.
So between the two families.
I saw at that time that the racial tension was real high.
And my dad was quite conscious there and there was safety.
But being home and enjoying being home,
I didn't really focus on it that much.
Then I was assigned to March Air Base in California.
And I moved my family there with me and got the kids involved in school.
And at that time, I was,
Master Sergeant.
And I became,
shifted in a big communications organization.
And I didn't hear anything and moved from my dad.
Because we didn't communicate that much because he had his thing going to head
mind going.
My Air Force career and kids in school now.
And on the morning.
Monday morning, January 10, 1966, I received a telephone call from one of my
dad's sisters who lived in Compton, then South Central LA, Compton, California.
And I was informed of what had happened.
The house had been fire bombed.
And it was like two or three o'clock in the morning,
and built me up out of a deep sleep.
I was living in my own house downtown, the boat house downtown, with my family.
And that was really a shock.
I wasn't too surprised because what I had seen, but at that time, it was a shock.
So I worked my wife around and told her what had happened.
And I proceeded then to get ready to go to work, put my uniform on.
And so while sitting after I got ready to go, I had time to think.
Couldn't call anybody because what the house had been burned destroyed.
And there was no telephone communication.
So I'm here and I just waiting on my, to find out what my next move is going to be.
So in my thoughts, I said, you know what?
I know the, how blacks are treated in the justice system.
Because I'm a grown man, I'm 35 years old.
In Mississippi.
And something told me, go to the FBI office in Riverside.
And tell them about what has happened and express my desire.
What I would like to see happened in my dead's case.
I reported downtown Riverside, California, Federal Building.
I was standing outside the FBI office when they came to work.
There's two or three gentlemen came in and regreated one another, went over to the office.
It's going to help you and I told them about it.
Let me see if we already know about it.
Because they were keeping up with these five bombers apparently on the, on that system.
And long story short, I says, I have one request.
I do not want any law enforcement officers, people on my dead's case, known from Mississippi.
I was outside of Mississippi.
I'm all the way to the FBI.
I have top secret DSI clearance.
I'm all the way up.
What's going on now?
And that one, the FBI also looked at me and he says, hold on a minute.
Are you telling me that you end up the integrity of the FBI?
I never would forget.
I'd like to record it on my brain.
And I told him, I didn't see that.
I told you what my desire was.
And from that time on, I found out later that I was being trained.
I was an observation.
One of the reasons being is, on my security clearance and my position, because I was in charge of base-style communication
percent of, at 50 people working and all kind of intelligence stuff, very super sensitive thing.
And the commanding officer when I left going home, who was a colonel, called me in his office and told me, do not compromise my position.
You know, how did they think you might do that?
What was it?
I had access to it.
So they think, but what did they think you would do with it?
Well, you know, we've had people, you know, disurden and going on and doing crazy stuff.
Just want to let me know that my commitment was to the Air Force.
Well, my commitment is also to my family.
I'm not going to kill a career of 15 years going home, you know, and do some crazy stuff.
No. But that was okay.
And I don't recall him ever telling me, you know, he regret what happened to my dad, because I wasn't focused on that.
But when I went by the first sergeant, you know, who was a good friend of mine, you know, big outfit and I know other people,
he looked me as kind of shook his head like, dang.
And the meantime, I went on in and started preparing to come home.
And I arrived home. That was on, I left Los Angeles Airport midnight on that Monday night.
I got reservations on, I arrived in New Orleans and next morning and got a plate coming out of New Orleans to home.
And during my trip home, I saw this one guy on the plane.
I didn't notice it at the time, but the same guy that I saw on the plane at boarder to plane at midnight in L.A.
And we got New Orleans, had to change planes a couple of times because we were having difficulty.
And finally, I called a bus and came on the bus when I got to the site. I saw the same guy again, but I never connected the dots.
They already had somebody?
I already had somebody on me.
And that person stayed on me for a long time because when I got back to my job, I had to be at home for two weeks.
And there, one of the guys in my department where all of the messages on the base, all kind of clear,
I said, going through my facility that I'm in charge of, they never, never did identify me as being the guy who sees everything that go wrong.
The message comes across to them about my activity.
My analysis guy showed it to me.
So then, you know, I said, hey, these people don't know I'm a Negro or whatever.
And so I said, well, they've been keeping up with me.
But in the meantime, coming home to bury my dad and what happened, this is the most essential part.
My dad, the father of eight children, seven boys and a girl, seven of his sons, including me, served a total of 78 years on active duty,
during the Korean and Vietnam era and beyond.
We were serving our nation, protecting the very country that neglected to protect my family from the tourist forces here.
My dad and mom slept in shifts for years, which my mom probably told you about.
For years while we were throughout the world, what, protecting the nation and my country couldn't protect me.
Coming home to that devastated site that morning when I arrived.
And I looked at the burned off facilities, which you, I think, you've probably seen pictures of.
And I went to the morgue and looked at my dad.
That was probably the worst days of my life.
I mean, that was horrible.
But I, I said, hey, you're the oldest kid.
You've got a responsibility.
You've been around.
Your mom, your sister, been burned.
Your dad's dead.
My family's homeless.
The law enforcement people everywhere.
The reporters everywhere.
Kurosda and the Seekas everywhere to burn down site.
Some grievings.
Some, whatever.
But I got to deal with this issue and then the burden is on my shoulder.
Okay?
And having that responsibility as I grew up in the Air Force, prepared me for a lot of tough stuff.
But it was not prepared to deal with this.
But I said, it's over now.
You got to do it.
So I just barked it out.
And I started dealing with the objective.
I mean, immediately.
I was dead, you know, as far as I'm concerned.
Yeah, he's dead.
But I don't let this get in the way of what I have to do.
Constantly, I got good family and I had some help.
But the decision was on around me, being the oldest son, because that's just where we were raised.
And in the meantime, that contact with my other brothers, my name was coming in.
And the family didn't prepare for the funeral and all this other stuff.
Now that was a very tough time.
I don't know if there's never been another time in my life.
And it wasn't my dad's death comes.
But the way he died and the contribution he'd made society and the contributions he sent,
all of us retired from the military and would auto-medist charge and would actulates.
You know, five full of things that we did that we learned the home to do right.
And we're good soldiers.
There's no black mark nowhere and we deal with this.
So, and I looked at it and I said, well, my praise for defending my country was to what?
What happened to it?
That's what my country thought on me, because this did not have to happen.
The oath that my brothers not took, hey, we lived up to it.
Wherever they were going to send us, that's where we were going to go and we were going to do what we had to do.
That's the way we, but the oath that those people who took to protect my family, they did not do it.
And I fought my country for not what, making them do that.
Now, I still love my country, but I still don't say, hey, my country could have done a better than that.
If I can do this for my country, if I can, my country could do this for my family.
And it took me a while to get over that.
But I never thought about being vindictive that ain't me.
But you, these things go through because what you have to be denied the opportunity that you gave all you were for to try to have.
And that was tough.
When your father was killed, were all your brothers who served in the military?
Were they already in the military or did some of them join after?
No, no, no. All of us had gone in and drafted.
Yes. Well, they said join.
But they were in the military. I don't know how they, you know, why all of them got there.
Being old as I was at first.
When my dad was killed, it was for us on active duty.
I was in California.
My brother next to me, the second known, he was career.
He was on Chemi Island off of Alaska.
My other brother was in Germany and I had one in Florida.
And my brother, Harold, who just returned from career and ended his commitment to the service.
On a bloody discharge, he was in the house that night.
So the time that my dad, my mom and dad were sleeping in shifts to avoid what eventually happened.
They had five sons, served on active duty in the military.
And for us four sons that come home in uniform and buried my dad because of what these race haters,
all because he's the wrong race, he's the wrong color.
But he's born in this country.
He was a good citizen, well start of, a family good citizen.
And as far as I'm concerned, we wouldn't better know about it, but hey, my family had,
and as far as I'm going to do the good job and race, it must be good citizens.
And we live by that code today.
Did anybody at the time recognize that fact about all of you serving your country?
Other than the fact that we came home, you know, we'd be in the newspaper,
if this sergeant came home, that one came home.
No, no.
No special.
No.
And the contradiction you're pointing out?
Right.
Nobody pointed out.
Can you talk about what your family's done over the years to try to pursue?
You know, there's probably no justice in this case, but to make sure that some people were held accountable?
Yes.
My mom is a lady that I have the utmost respect for.
And she gets that respect from all of us.
You know, she's number one in our life.
She's the leader of our family.
Even though we were all men, she went through all this, and we never overshadow her.
You may notice that.
We don't do that.
And as a result of what happened to our family, she chose not to leave.
She chose to stay here because she had those two kids.
She was a teacher.
And she had brothers living in Washington another place that were financially in good shape.
One brother, the dentist, others worked for the federal government in Washington at good jobs.
They said, hey, leader please, come here.
She thought she was on the ground.
And she stayed, built a house on the same spot.
And raised those two kids, Dennis and Betty, that she had by my dad,
okay, my brother and my sister.
We don't have no haves.
Everybody's brothers and sisters sent in the college degrees.
They were professionals and went all out in their life.
And she built a home with assistance.
And continued her life, became an election commissioner.
In the same district where my dad was killed for three terms.
And she had more terms.
And the whites put her in all because of the kind of life that she lived.
It wasn't because they felt sorry for her.
That was probably a part of it, a little sympathy there.
But because of the life that she did and the way that she lived her life after this catastrophic event.
And then she had to, what, live through all of these clansmen's trials.
She testified over seven to something times.
And after the 14 who did this were indicted.
And they brought some to justice.
And finally, they couldn't get soundbiles after they tried him four times.
Because what the jury had clansmen in there.
She went through a whole lot.
And as a result, she maintained the family nucleus, the location.
And we all came back home around her.
And built for you see we are today.
She held everything in tag.
And to me, that demonstrate a whole lot about who we are as a family.
And they know big eyes and little news.
We just, we just a family committed to where we were raised.
And we got a lady here that my dad chose to be his wife down the road that we totally respect to the end.
And that we do.
It's such a thing to have to go through.
And it seems like that you all have handled it as well as anybody could.
Coming out of this situation after we got the conviction of soundbowers.
Did that help?
Yeah, you know, soundbowers was, was, was in 1998.
The Medgev was a case service, the opportunity for us to get soundbowers back in the courtroom.
We won't go through all of that.
Can you just, I mean, we know, but can you say who soundbowers is for people?
Oh, yes, for sure.
The soundbowers was the leader of the white nace of the Clucleic clan in Jones County in, in, in law of Mississippi area.
And he had power that was equal to the governor's what while former clansmen told me that he was, he was highly regarded.
And he could go to the governor's office anytime.
And he had told former clansmen, other clansmen in his organization, you can kill a, kill a black male on Nigger and Mississippi.
You don't have to worry about going jail.
Now, I got this from former clansmen, okay?
So sound, soundbowers was, was a man that was beyond reach during that error.
And to get him back into the courtroom in 1998, which required a lot of work, a weed, our family worked with the, with the law enforcement people to get him back to the courtroom.
And I was the primary leader on that with the assistance of the family.
Now, but you got to have a spokesperson, my mom and I, and my brother Dennis, he helped a lot also.
And we were, with the news media and all and created enough attention on it.
Created, we created enough attention, you know, until we got to support of the community because what?
We, we go through all these phases and only got five convictions out of the previous trials that it was held in the 1960s, late 1968, 6768.
But we never could get Sam. Now we have a chance to get Sam.
For Sam and Sam was convicted on the 21st of August,
by jury verdict, 1998, somewhere around 22 and 3 o'clock a day I'll never forget, for what he had done.
And he was carted off to the jail and there to prison. And he died in November of 2006 in prison.
What did it mean for you that he was?
Justice finally, even though it was 32 years late,
we should have been better, but it finally came and was very pleased.
There were no high fives, there were no celebrations.
We was glad to be treated equally in the justice system as others, even though it took a long time to do it.
It took 32 years to do this.
And the good thing that I see with my family and I give this to my mom because she stayed here and dealt with it,
is that we didn't give up.
And the community worked with us and didn't allow us to give up.
We had these memorial services every year on January 10th, and you know, about that time at the church to keep it alive.
In the Hubs City Professional Men's Club, which is an all black men's club, in Hedgesburg, my brother was a part of that album.
They have a program every year. For 25 years, they kept it alive.
And we got good support when it came time for the trials 98.
We had good support from all the law enforcement officers.
I never got one bad telephone call.
One of my neighbors that I grew up with, a white guy told me he said, Bernie, he said, they're still out there.
I'm not sure if I was you, I'd be doing this.
Well, I thank him, and I appreciate it, and I moved on.
Because I'd seen worse things in life. My dad gave his life, at least I can do what we can do as a family.
Is it keep on doing what we had to do to be justice, at least try to.
Okay. This photo is of my father, Vernon Elf Damage, senior, back in his young days.
This photo is a copy of the home site that was destroyed by the fire bombing on January 10th,
which involved the right nights of the Clucula clan of Laurel, Mississippi, led by Sam Bowers.
This is the burned out structure of the family home.
I've taken about three or four days after the fire bombing, those standing overlooking the site are my brothers
who were serving in the military own active duty at other locations, including me, and I'm a part of this photo also.
Okay, this is a copy of the grocery store, proud to the fire bombing.
The grocery store was adjacent to the house about 150 feet away.
This is the burned out site of the grocery store, with two of my dad's son, my brothers, looking at the burned out debris falling the fire bombing.
This is a copy. Photo is of the family members falling the film of my father's film, which took place the exact date I'm not sure is the weekend falling January 10th, which was on a Saturday.
This is a copy of the call, which was in the cardboard, which was destroyed along with the fire bombing.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.